عربيه على حفل زفاف ابن دونالد ترامب
الصغرى من الفساتين الى المجوهرات وحتى
العريس
[موسيقى]
ايام احتفل الرئيس الامريكي السابق دون
ترامب بزفاف ابنته تفلي على الشاب
اللبناني مايكل بولس وهو ابن اللبناني
مسعد بولس الذي هاجر مع عائلته في
السبعينات الى الولايات المتحده
العروسه
الذي يتزين بحجر المسيح يبلغ وزنه 13
قراطا وسعره مليون ومئه الف دولار وهو من
تصميم اللبناني سامر حليمه الذي يعد من
ابرز تجار المجوهرات في مدينه نيويورك
وقد تالقت سفني خلال الحفل بثوب زفاف حامل
توقيع الموصل من لبناني
[موسيقى]
كان لافتا ان البدله السوداء التي تداها
العريس مايكل بولت في الحفل كانت ايضا من
تصميم دار اليسا
باللون الازرق
[موسيقى]
كان لبنانينيا وامريكا